arriving for the virtual summit eu
leaders were keeping their thoughts to
themselves ready for a meeting which was
meant to be about trade but which many
believed would be dominated by the war
in ukraine so we also made very clear
that china should
if not support
at least not interfere with our
sanctions
we discussed that and also the fact that
no european citizen would understand any
support
to russia's ability to wage war
the view in beijing is more nuanced as
traditional friends and allies of the
russians they have not supported
sanctions against ministers in moscow
underlying this summit is the reality of
bilateral trade between the eu and china
10 times bigger than that between china
and russia and worth hundreds of
billions of dollars to both sides every
year
these links are so extensive that
neither side wants them threatened but
there are some industrialists here in
europe who worry they may be too
dependent on chinese imports
while governments have a new
determination to prioritize both dealing
with the war in ukraine and with the
human rights situation in china
some analysts believe that in doing so
ministers are not understanding the
strategic view of the government in
beijing
china is following its own interests
always has been following its own
interests it is one of our biggest
mistakes to look at china through the
lenses of our
interests
and in that perspective china is only
making mistakes but why should they
follow our interests and do what we ask
them or
even order them to do sometimes so china
is proud enough self-confident enough to
follow its own interests and that will
not change today
meaning that if the europeans want
chinese help to end the war in ukraine
they need first to persuade them it's in
their interests
and so far that has not happened
dominick kane al jazeera berlin